السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في وقفتنا
التحليليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوميه نحو اسرائيل يتقطر مزيد من
المسؤولين في الاداره الامريكيه على خلفيه
تطورات الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه جاء
الدور هذه المره على وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستن في زياره ليست الاولى من نوعها
منذ السابعه من اكتوبر الماضي اوستن قال
في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يو اف جالنت انه ناقش مع
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين مستقبل غزه بعد
الحرب كما اضاف انه تباحث معهم بشان كيفيه
اداره الحرب على غزه بالنظر الى الطبيعه
الخاصه لساحه المعركه حيث يوجد كثير من
المدنيين يرى الجانب الامريكي ان ذلك
يستدعي الانتقال الى مرحله جديده تعتمد
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه والوسائل الدقيقه
في استهداف قيادات حماس تجري هذه التطورات
بينما يتواصل الحديث عن خلاف بين بايدن
ونتنياهو بشان كيفيه اداره الحرب والتعامل
مع الخسائر المدنيه الفادحه الناجمه عنها
نتنياهو الذي اشرك اوستن في جلسه لمجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي صرح بعد لقائه بوزير
الدفاع الامريكي قال ملتزمون بتحقيق النصر
كامل على حماس وسوف نفعل ذلك وفيما
تناقلته وسائل اعلام مختلفه بشان لقاء
امريكي قطري اسرائيلي في بولندا لمناقشه
احتمال التوصل الى صفقه جديده لتبادل
الاسرى شددت حركه حماس على انه لا صفقه
جديده لتبادل الاسرى قبل الوقف الكامل
لحرب اسرائيل على غزه والانسحاب
منها معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستديو
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من الدوحه كذلك الدكتور مهند
مصطفى الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه ومن
الدوحه كذلك الدكتور لقاء مكي الباحث
الاول بمركز الجزيره للدراسات نرحب بهم
جميعا ولكن قبل ان نشرع في النقاش حول
زياره اوستن وما ترتب عنها وما ما هي
المقالات التي ستجري نتابع هذه الصور التي
بثتها كتائب القسام بما قالت انها رساله
لاسرى اسرائيليين في غزه و هي موجهه
للحكومه الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
وعوائلهم
ر
[موسيقى]
ش و خير انتش خير نا انتشت
خير
لكنا اذا اذا كانت هذه رساله من ثلاثه من
المحتجزين لدى حركه حماس هؤلاء من عمر
معين ومع ذلك يقولون لا دعونا لا تدعو
نشيخ هنا وهم يشعرون بالاسى لانهم هم من
الجيل المؤسس لهذا الجيش وبالتالي يخشون
على انفسهم ان تكون نهايتهم على يد هذا
الجيش سناخذ تعليق قصير من كل من ضيوفنا
الثلاثه ثم نمر الى زياره اوستن لاسرائيل
ومباحثاته هناك لنبدا باللواء فايز
الدويري يا سيدي انا اعتقد رسالتهم ستكون
صادمه
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي كما كان قتل الاسرى
الثلاثه الذي لوحوا بالاعلام البيضاء
وقتلوا وا اعتبرت ماساه لا يمكن تج جاوزها
او احتمالها هؤلاء من مؤسسي الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهذا هو مصيرهم ويناشدون لا
تتركون نشيخ او نبوت بغض النظر عن المفرده
اذا سيكون وقعها على الداخل الاسرائيلي
اعتقد اما مكافئ او يزيد عن الخبر الذي تم
تداوله عن قتل الجيش الاسرائيلي
لثلاثه من المحتجزين دكتور مهند مصطفى نعم
يعني هذا الفيديو هو جزء من عمليه تصعيد
النقاش والصراع في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي حول موضوع ملف الاسر والرهائن
ولا شك انه هذا الفيديو سوف يؤجج نضال
واحتجاج العائلات الاسرائيليه ضد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من اجل الذهاب الى صفقه تبادل
اسرى رهائن لانه هذا بالنسبه لحماس هو
الشرط لوقف اطلاق النار ولذلك هذا الفيديو
سوف يساهم في تاجيج حاله التناقض الموجود
الان بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبين قطاعات
واسعه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي عندما قال
هؤلاء الرهائن باللغه العبريه لا تتركون
نشيخ هم يستحضرون في الذاكره الاسرائيليه
الجندي والطيار رون اراد الذي تخلت عنه
اسرائيل في اواخر الثمانينات وبقي حتى هذه
اللحظه جندي مفقود وهو ترك اثرا عميقا في
داخل الوعي والمخيال الاسرائيلي حتى هذه
اللحظه دكتور لقاء مكي هي حرب نفسيه
مستمره من قبل قسام ضد اي
اسرائيل نجحت كثيرا في السابق واظنها
ستمضي الان في نفس النجاح لا سما انها
جاءت بعد سلسله احداث خاصه
ب خصوصا مقتل الاسرى الثلاثه هناك شعور
كبير بالعار داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي بسبب
قتل هؤلاء وحتى ان رئيس الاركان قال ليت
الزمن يعود ونحصل على فرصه اخرى لانقاذ
الاسرى بمعنى ان الجيش تصرف بطريقه غير
مهنيه وغير محترفه وناهيك عن الوضع
الداخلي في اسرائيل هو استمرار الحرب
النفسيه وجاء في سياق معين وفي وقت
توقيتات معينه ربما تؤثر بشكل بالغ على
القرار الاسرائيلي نعم هذا هذا ثاني فيديو
اليوم للاعلام العسكري دكتور لواء فايز
الدويري واحد للعمليات وثم هذه ل ما يمكن
ان نسميه بنداء استغاثه تقريبا وياتي في
ظل زياره اوستن الى الى اسرائيل الملاحظ
في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقده مع جلنت وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يقول لا نملي اطارا
زمنيا للعمليه يعني واشنطن لا نملي اطارا
زمنيا للعمليه العسكريه في غزه فهذه عمليه
اسرائيل ماذا يمكن ان يفهم من هذا يعني هو
تراجع عن تصريحات الرئيس بايدن الرئيس
بايدن وضع اطارا زمنيا وتحدث عن الكريسماس
انه يجب انهاء العمليه ثم كثر الحديث في
ذلك اليوم ان الخلافات ما بين القياده
البيت الابيض والقياده السياسيه في
اسرائيل ولكن في الزيارات المتتاليه اوستن
وما والان وزير
الدفاع يبدو ان الجانب الامريكي هو اللي ب
بدا يرضى للمطالب الاسرائيليه ولاكان
الجانب الامريكي لا يملك القوى الفاعله
المؤثره على القرار الاسرائيلي علما انه
يدرك ان امكانات الجيش الاسرائيلي بناء
على ما جرى خلال 73 يوم غير قادر على
تحقيق الاهداف لكنه لا يستطيع الاملاء
وخرج نتنياهو لا يزال يصرح انه ما بعد
حماس وكان حماس انتهت علما ان حماس تصعد
في عملياتها العسكريه وما نشرته من
فيديوهات في هذا اليوم يثبت حقيقه ان لا
تزال يدها هي العليا في الميدان هل هل
معنى ذلك دكتور مهند مصطفى ان اسرائيل
ستفهم هذا الكلام على انه اطلاق ليدها
خاصه وان المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه بنتاجون صرح اصلا واوستن في
طريقه الى هناك سيقول ان اوستن ورئيس
الاركان وهما معا في هذه الزياره سيؤكد
الدعم الثابت لدفاع اسرائيل عن نفسه يعني
ما زلنا في اسطوانه الدفاع عن النفس رغم
كل ما شهدناه في هذين الشهرين نعم يعني
بلا شك هذه التصريحات ايضا تنضم الى
التصريحات التي كانت لجون سلفان باعطاء
الدعم لاسرائيل باستمرار عملياتها
العسكريه وهنا علينا ان نفهم نقطه مهمه
جدا ان اسرائيل ماضيه في هذه العمليه
العسكريه لان هنالك في عاملان مركزيين او
ثلاث عوامل مركزيه تدعم اسرائيل في في هذه
الحرب اولا الجيش الاسرائيلي معني
بالاستمرار بهذه الحرب بسبب ما حدث له في
السابع من اكتوبر الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يد
يوقف الحرب حتى يعيد هيبته امام المجتمع
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو يريد الاستمرار بهذه
الحرب من اجل البقاء السياسي والحفاظ على
سلطته وكرسيه في الحكم واعاده شعبيته وحتى
هذه اللحظه المجتمع الاسرائيلي في مجمله
مازال داعم للعمليات
العسكريه رغم الاختلاف والتباين في داخل
المجتمع حول اولويات هذه الحرب هذه الثلاث
عوامل الجيش ونتنياهو والمجتمع
الاسرائيلي ما زالوا مصرين ومؤيدين
لاستمرار هذه الحرب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تفهم انها حتى لو طلبت من
اسرائيل التوقف عن هذه الحرب فان اسرائيل
لن تستجيب لها ولذلك يضغط الامريكيون ليس
على وقف اطلاق النار وانما على الانتقال
الى المرحله الثانيه من الحرب والتي يعني
تتمحور حول وقف العمليات العسكريه بشكل
شامل والقصف المكثف العشوائي على قطاع غزه
والانتقال الى عمليات عينيه مركزيه تستهدف
حماس بشكل خاص سنتوقف عند ملامح هذه
المرحله الثانيه التي يفترض ان تبدا في
منتصف الشهر المقبل ولكن الكتور لقاء مكي
جاءت زياره اوستن بعد انتقادات امريكيه ل
القصف العشوائي وهذا تعبير لبايدن لتزايد
الاعداد المدنيين الذين سقطوا في في غزه
وايضا لانتقادات لتعثر دخول المساعدات هل
هل معنى ذلك بان اوستن عوض ان يراكم على
هذه التصريحات تراجع كما يبدو لا اعتقد
هناك في تصريحات اوستن يمكن ملاحظه يعني
ثلاثه اشياء اساسيه الاولى هي تاييده
لاسرائيل و هذا امر متوقع حقيقه لا اعتقد
انه من
الحكمه توقع ان تتخلى امريكا عن اسرائيل
في خضم حرب على الاقل من الناحيه العلنيه
وستواصل دعمها لانه الجانب الاستخباري
والعسكري سيستمر بغض النظر عن اي خلافات
سياسيه الامر الثاني او النقطه الثانيه في
حديث اوستن هو حديث عن الجانب الانساني
وهذا نفس السياق الامريكي الذي يقال منذ
الهدنه وحتى الان انه يجب مراعاه المدنيين
وزياده الدعم الانساني من الممرات
الانسانيه وهذا لم يتغير حتى في حديث
اوستن اليوم هو تاكيدا لكلامك يا دكتور
لقا مكي البيت الابيض الان في في خبر عاجل
يقول نواصل العمل على التوصل الى اتفاق
هدنه انسانيه جديده يعني هذا البعد
الانساني مازال قائما في الخطاب الامريكي
على الاقل نعم ولكن يعني هذا احتاج توضيح
ربما بعد النقطه الثالثه وهي انه وستن
اليوم وهو وزير دفاع وليس سياسي طرح مساله
ح حل الدولتين في داخل اسرائيل رغم رفض
حكومه نتنياهو للمبدا من الاساس هذا
التكرار من قبل وزير الدفاع لحل الدولتين
في سياق الحديث عن دعم اسرائيل في حاله
حرب هو بالتاكيد محاوله لاثاره النقطه
اساسيه لغزه ما بعد الحرب وهو السياق
الامريكي الذي لم تتخن عنه واشنطن في سياق
معرفه ماذا تريد بعد غزه المهم الان ان
القضيه الانسانيه فقط هذه الملاحظه
بالحقيقه ليس حبا لاهل غزه يعني يجب ان
نفهم هذا القضيه تتعلق بمحاوله استيعاب
ردود الفعل الدوليه الجامحه ضد اسرائيل
سواء بالغرب او في المنطقه الشرق الاوسط
ومحاوله يعني يعني لملمت هذه الردود الفعل
يعني على الاقل لصالح بايدن الذي هبطت
شعبيته اليوم الى ادنى مستوياتها 34% تيد
فهذا الامر في الحقيقه يزعج ويحرج اداره
بايدن
اسرائيل غير مهتمه لكن هناك ضغوط شديده
تمارس على الولايات المتحده من حلفائه
العرب الغربيين بانه اسرائيل يجب ان تخفف
من حده القتل يعني لا تتوقف ولكن تخفف من
حده القتل منعا لاحراج امام الراي العام
هذا هو السبب الاساسي لقصه يعني الدعم
الانساني اما القصه الاخرى اللي متعلقه
بدعم اسرائيل فلا اظن انها ستتوقف حتى
تحقيق مبادئ مشتركه فيما بينهما نعم عندما
نتحدث عن مرحله جديده اللواء فاز الدويري
هذه المرحله الجديده اشار اليها جاك
سوليمان والان استن جاء يفترض على ان
يعاين بالضبط خصائص هذه المرحله ما ينشر
الان عن هذه المرحله انه مرحله يفترض ان
تبدا مثل ما ذكرت في منتصف يناير المقبل
يعني في العام الجديد ستكون مرتكزه على
مجموعات صغيره من النخبه تقوم بعمليات
دقيقه بناء على معلومات استخباراتيه دقيقه
والهدف مره اخرى خرى هو القضاء على حماس
وقياداتها واطلاق سراح المخطوفين يعني ما
لم يتحقق بما سبق يمكن ان يتحقق بهذا لا
اعتقد ذلك قد ينجحوا في تنفيذ عمليات
اغتيال قد ينجحوا او لا اجزم قد يحتمل ان
يستطيعوا ان يجمعوا معلومات معينه خاصه في
ظل اي وجود خمس وكالات استخباراتيه موجوده
في مكث في قاعده في غلاف غزه وموجوده في
تل ابيب والطائرات الاستطلاع ال
البريطانيه وكافه هذه لديها كم هائل من
وسائل جمع المعلومات وبالتالي قد قد
يتمكنوا اي لتنفيذ عمليه اغتيال هذا جل ما
يفعلوه او قد يستطيع الوصول الى مكان ما
يوجد فيه بع بعض الاسرى هذا ما يمكن
انجازه لكن السؤال الحديث الان عن مستقبل
غزه كانه تم القضاء على حماس حماس من حيث
القدره على اداره معاركها هي في تصاعد كنا
نتحدث قبل في ثلاثه اسابيع عن موضوع
القياده والسيطره لا الان الوضع اصبح اكثر
وضوحا هناك ثلاث مستويات من القياده
والسيطره سي 2 سي 3 سي4 كوماند اند كنترول
كوماند كنترول كومكيش كوماند كنترول
كومكيش كومبيوتر الان القسام اثبت يقينا
انه يملك السي ف وبالتالي هو يمارس منظومه
قياده وسيطره ولا يمكن ل لتنظيم ي يمسك
بهذا الشكل ان يتم القضاء عليه بسهوله اذا
هذا كلام لا يمكن تحقيقه او دعني اقول
يصعب جدا
تحقيقه مع ذلك دكتور مهند مصطفى اليوم
صحيفه المحلل العسكري لهارد عموس هاريل
يقول انه حتى مع هذه حتى مع هذه العمليه
الجديده في مطلع يناير هناك شكوك في تحقيق
اهداف العمليه المعلنه وهو اخضع حماس
واعاده المخطوفين ويشير وهذه نقطه مهمه
جدا يقول التاييد الشعبي الكبير للمناوره
البريه اصبح اليوم ممزوجا بالقلق وبشك
ويشبه المزاج الحالي الشعبي في اسرائيل
بما حصل في نهايات الغزو الاسرائيلي
لبيروت عام 282 عندما بدا يتاكل الدعم
الشعبي وبالتالي اضطرت اسرائيل الى ان ترك
العاصمه بيروت نعم يعني هذا صحيح هنالك في
يعني تاكل تدريجي بطيء بطيء ولكنه هنالك
في تاكل وهذا ذكرناه سابقا وهذا التاكل
نابع يعني من عاملين اساسيين العامل الاول
هو طرح موضوع الاصر والرهائن كقضيه وهدف
مركزي للحرب ولذلك هم يريدون حل هذه
القضيه ك ووضعها كاولو اولى من الحرب
والقضيه الثانيه او العامل الثاني هو
الخسائر الكبيره للجيش الاسرائيلي في قطاع
غزه ودون دون تحقيق اهداف عسكريه ملموسه
ودون ودون تقديم انجاز عسكري ملموس للجيش
الاسرائيلي هذين العاملين يعني يؤديان الى
تاكل في دعم المجتمع الاسرائيلي للعمليات
العسكريه ولكنه ما زال كبيرا هذا التاكل
هو تدريجي وبطيء طبعا هنالك في عامل ثالث
دخل هو ايضا يساهم في تاكل الدعم لهذه
الحرب وهو وجود بنيامين نتنياهو كرئيس
حكومه يقود هذه الحرب وقناعه ايه قطعات
واسعه من المجتمع الاسرائيلي ان نتنياهو
يقود هذه الحرب ويضع اهدافها بناء على
مصالحه الشخصيه ولكن هنالك في نقطه هامه
جدا يعني في اسرائيل انا في اعتقادي انه
نتنياهو سيكون فرح بالانتقال الى المرحله
القادمه من الحرب لانه هذا ينسجم مع ما
يفكر مع مصالحه نتنياهو قال اننا نريد ان
ان نبقى في غزه نسيطر عسكريا وامنيا
والانتقاد الى المرحله الثانيه من الحرب
هذا يعني اطاله الحرب اكثر واكثر لانه
الانتقال الى عمليات عينيه عمليات مركزه
عمليات بناء على استخبارات ايه ايه ايه
معلوماتيه هذا معناه البقاء في قطاع غزه
واحتلال قطاع غزه وفي اعتقادي ان الاداره
الامريكيه في هذه النقطه من حيث تدري او
لا تدري تنسجم مع اهداف نتنياهو في اطاله
الحرب وفي البقاء في قطاع غزه واحتلال
قطاع غزه عسكريا وامنيا واطه الحرب هذا
كله يخدم الاهداف السياسيه لبنيامين
نتنياهو لا ادري اذا كانت الاداره
الامريكيه تعلم ذلك او لا تعلم ذلك ولكن
اعتقد ان نتنياهو يريد ذلك يريد البقاء في
غزه وفي نفس الوقت يريد ان يخفف العب
العسكري
والعبء الدولي على اسرائيل من اجل البقاء
في قطاع غزه بمعنى ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تسهل على اسرائيل البقاء
واحتلال قطاع غزه وتسهيل وتخفيف الضغط
الدولي والعب
والعبء المدني الداخلي والاقتصادي على
اسرائيل من خلال الانتقال الى الى عمليات
عينيه ومع ذلك دون وقف اطلاق النار او دون
انسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه من قطاع غزه
هذا امر في منتهى الخطوره وهو يصب في صالح
نتنياهو وفي صالح الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الاستمرار في البقاء واحتلال قطاع غزه
ولكن هنا هارتز دكتور مهند مصطفى لا تتفق
معك وسان قل السؤال لدكتور لقاكي هاردز
ماذا تقول تقول نتنياهو يسير عكس ما جاء
من اجله اوستن اولا هو ليس مستعدا لتقليص
زخم الحرب الحالي هذا اولا ثانيا المرور
الى مرحله ثانيه مع بدايه يناير يحتاج الى
استعدادات عسكريه لوجستيه من نوع خاص وهذا
لم يشرع فيه بالمره فهل يمكن ان يكون
نتنياهو عامل عرقله بالكامل للتوجه
الامريكي مهما كان محدودا فيما يتعلق بغزه
نعم هذا ممكن وممكن يتم من خلال تجاوز
المهله المعلنه يعني مهله نهايه السنه قد
يجري تجاوزها لمده اسبوع او اسبوعين فقط
لاثبات ان واشنطن لم تضع حدود نهائيه او
توقيتات نهائيه لاسرائيل وانها عند كلمتها
بترك اسرائيل تفعل ما تشاء لكن توقيت
انتهاء المعارك الضخمه او القصف الكثيف له
نهايات بالتاكيد ربما خلال الاسبوعين
الاولين من عام 24 القصه هنا ان اوستن
زيارته لاسرائيل في هذه المرحله هي في
الواقع لترتيبات ما بعد الضربات المكثفه
المرحله الثانيه وليس لقصه البحر الاحمر
لانه كان ممكن يجري اتصالاته بدون ان يكون
في اسرائيل يعني قصه البحر الاحمر لا
يحتاج ان يذهب الى اسرائيل و حضر مجلس
الحرب من اجلها القصه تتعلق بالمرحله
الثانيه من الحرب وهو تحدث عن قصه
الاستخبارات وتوفير قدرات استخباريه
لاسرائيل لا ندري تحديدا ان كانت الولايات
المتحده قد منحت اسرائيل خلال الشهور
الشهرين الماضيين او 70 يوم الماضيين كل
شيء من امكانيات استخباريه وعسكريه ربما
لان دوما هناك اشياء تحتفظ بها واشنطن
لنفسها على الصعيد الامني استخباري
والعسكري ربما ما ان كانت قد احتفظت بشيء
فست طلق سراح هذه الامور هذه المعلومات من
اجل خدمه اسرائيل ومن اجل منح اسرائيل
امكانيات اضافيه خلال الفتره كحافز
لاسرائيل من اجل الكف عن القصف المكثف
وانجاز ما تريده واشنطن من مرحليه لهذه
الحرب نعم عندما نتحدث عن اي صفقه جديده
لموضوع الاسرى
والمحتجزين نرى ما انعكاسات ما قام به
اوستن الان على هذا الملف لكن لنشاهد مره
اخرى الفيديو الذي بدانا به ثم نواصل
[موسيقى]
النقاش
د
[موسيقى]
ين
ز
بخ مخير بخور مخير
[موسيقى]
تشخخ لواء فايز الدويري الى اي مدى يمكن
ان يحرك هذا النوع من الاشرطه قضيه صفقه
جديده لان هناك الان اجتماعات قطريه
اسرائيليه امريكيه في في وارسو ولكن يبدو
ان هناك عقده كبيره هذه المره حماس تقول
لا تبادل على الاطلاق الا بعد وقف الحرب
والانسحاب من غز يا سيدي يعني الان الوصول
الى هدنه انسانيه كما جرى في المره
السابقه اعتقد من منظور استراتيجي هذه هي
ضربه مؤلمه جدا انا لست ضد الهدن
الانسانيه لكن اتحدث من بعد استراتيجي
تقيييم عسكري الان كم هو العدد 129 تقريبا
بهذا بهذا الحدود قد يكون هناك الرقم
مختلف عليه في اطر محدده جدا لكن اذا تم
انقاذهم وماذا ستفعل اسرائيل في غزه ماذا
ستفعل في حماس يعني الان الورقه الرابحه
بيد حماس هي وجود الرهائن والرهائن
العسكريين هؤلاء الذين تسجلوا الفيديو ولا
غيرهم من جنرالات لا يزالوا على راس عملهم
كانوا على راس العمل حتى السابع من اكتوبر
وبالتالي عندما تضع الكل مقابل الكل ومخرج
سياسي هي تعي ما تقول لانه تدمير غزه غزه
دمرت لم يبقى شيء الا ما نذر لم يدمر
غزه الشعب الحكومه الاسريه تهدف الى تهجير
الشعب بعد اطلاق راح الاسرى الا تتحقق
مطالب وزير الاثار الاسرائيلي نعم اعتقد
ان ستكون من منظور استراتيجي خطا كارثي
ترتكب حماس اذا وافقت على هدنه انسانيه
دون الحصول على وقف اطلاق نار شامل و
مضمون هل توافق دكتور مهند مصطفى ان قضيه
المحتجزين ورقه رابحه في ظل كل ما يجري
الان بالطبع يعني هذه الورقه الرابحه
لحركه حماس واعتقاد ان حركه حماس وضعت
موضوع وقف اطلاق النار مقابل تبادل اسرى
بشكل واضح بشكل بشكل مفهوم و وحماس تراهن
على ان يقوم المجتمع الاسرائيلي برفع هذه
القضيه كقضيه مركزيه من اجل وقف اطلاق
النار الان علينا ان نسمع هؤلاء الجنود
الذين جاءوا بال بالفيديو هم يتحدثون
يوجهون حديثهم باللغه العبريه بصيغه
المفرد وليس بصيغه الجماعه بمعنى انهم
يوجهون حديثهم الى بنيامين نتنياهو
تحديدا ويطالبونه بارجاع وهذا الامر يؤكد
ان نتنياهو ياخذ منحى وموقف معارض لوقف
اطلاق النار من اجل حل مشكله الاقصى
والرهائن هو بالنسبه له مستعد ان يضحي
فيهم من اجل الاستمرار في الحرب ولكن
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بدا يدرك يعني يعني
امرين الامر الاول ان هنالك في تناقض واضح
بين حل مشكله الاصر والرهائن وبين القضاء
على حركه حماس لا يمكن تحقيق الهدفين يمكن
تحقيق هدف واحد منهما هما هم يفضلون تحقيق
هدف حل الاصر والرهائن الامر الثاني هم
يعتقدون انه فقط من خلال تبادل اسرى فقط
من خلال صفقات تبادل اسرى يمكن ارجاع
الاسرى والرهائن الاسرائيليين الى الى
اسرائيل اريد ان اذكر ان اسرائيل اخر
عمليه عسكريه نجحت فيها ب بتحرير اسرى
اسرائيليين كان عام
1976 في عمليه عين طيبي منذ ذلك الحين
وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تنجح اي عمليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه باسترجاع مخطوف او رهينه او
اسير اسرائيلي واحد ولذلك المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وصل الى قناعه وهذه القناعه
سوف تضغط على على على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
من اجل الذهاب الى صفقه التبادل اصرى لان
هذا هو الحل الوحيد عادتهم وهذا معناه وقف
اطلاق النار نعم مع تصاعد احتجاجات ال
العائلات المخطوفين دكتور لقاء مكي ومع
استمرار المظاهرات المطالبه بوقف اطلاق
النار في عديد العواصم العالميه هل تتوقع
ان يتغير اي شيء في في المستقبل القريب
والله اعتقد ان ما تريده اسرائيل من امر
التفاوض مع قطر من خ وايضا الولايات
المتحده كشريك وطرحت هي موضوع اطلاق سراح
الاسرى الفلسطينيين ذوي
المحكومية
وحتى لو اطلاق سراح الجميع فهي لا تريد
وقف اطلاق النار اصلا عموما انا اعتقد ان
الامر بذاته بكامله عمليه التفاوض هي
محاوله لكسب الوقت وايضا محاوله لاستيعاب
غضب الشارع الاسرائيلي ليس ليست جديه
ونتنياهو يريدهم ميتين ولا يريدهم احياء
ليس ضروريا بالنسبه له حتى لو ماتوا
وبالتالي لا اظنه جاد في مساله التبادل او
الوصول الى حل مع حماس اليوم كان جالانت
واضح في تاكيده على تفكيك حماس وهذا
يتناقض تماما مع قصه الهدنه او قصه
التبادل الاسرى هو محاوله كل ما طال امد
التفاوض كل ما قلت حماسه الشاره باعتبار
انه يترقب ثم سيلقى العب على حماس
باعتبارها هي المتصلبه وهي الرافضه وكانت
اسرائيل مستعده للتبادل هذا هو باختصار
يعني انا اعتقد ان الامر فيه خدعه ومحاوله
من نتنيا هو لاستيعاب غضب الشارع
الاسرائيلي وكسب
الوقت ل خلال هذا التفاوض الذي قد يطول
بالتاكيد شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور لقاء مكي
شكرا ايضا دكتور مهند مصطفى وشكرا ايضا
لضيفنا هنا في الاستديو اللواء فايز
الدويري بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه المساحه التحليليه
موعدنا يتجدد غدا باذن الله تمام الثامنه
ونص بتوقيت مكه المكرمه